[Music]
okay everybody this is my spoiler review
of the northmen make sure you see the
film first before you watch this review
i was very excited for this film i'm a
huge robert eggers fan my favorite still
being the witch and then the lighthouse
i thought was excellent too not as good
as the witch but still loved it and this
film a little worried going in because i
know it was a different genre it still
had its taste of horror in it but it's
this big epic now revenge tale and i was
curious how robert eggers was going to
approach that especially the bigger
budget not being on a 24 anymore now
he's with focus features and seeing what
was going to come out of that and now
he's got also a different co-writer
which he does every film but this one
was co-written by
shone so
my thing about this film when you watch
it and i think that it just does
everything right in the department of
making a really strong revenge epic
viking tale right and that
the brutality of it
everything is so intense in it but
what was so disappointing about it to me
was knowing who's behind it in robert
eggers and that his films with the
lighthouse and the witch
you feel something from it and
you are thinking about it for days after
right it's a really smart script those
stories and that they end on like a
haunting
visual that stays with you it sticks
with you you feel right and that's the
most important thing of the films and
that's why i was worried he was doing a
revenge tale because a lot of times
you're just kind of
watching through one character's eyes
you know where it's going there's not
much leeway to be had and i was worried
that was going to kind of be a trap for
him and i do think it was eventually a
trap for him and i think that
it does what you need to do right to
make a good revenge story right and that
i enjoyed everything that was happening
in front of me i was very entertained by
it but there's this nagging thing in
your head if you felt this way that i
felt watching it that i know who's
behind this i know he's a guy who's
known for smart stories and why is this
story not trying that why isn't it
stimulating my brain why am i not
feeling anything from it why am i not
feeling that i'm learning something new
this was just again
a movie that the visuals felt unique and
fresh but the story did not you know
i've seen these story beats before over
and over again i've seen this message
before over and over again i've seen
this twist over and over again so
that's where i was incredibly
disappointed with this film and it's not
saying that i didn't like the film
though because i really like the film i
think it's super entertaining and i
think
it has one of the best scores we've had
in years i think having the same
cinematography always does doesn't hurt
him at all he's amazing and the
cinematography here was amazing i think
the production design the costume design
is awesome and
i do wish there was more william the foe
right because he's just a scene stealer
in all this and i also was a little
disappointed with anya taylor joyce
character i don't think she really has
much to do i don't think it's a great
character but she's great alexander
skarsgard crushes it right i think he
was perfect for this role i thought
nicole kidman i don't know if she didn't
fit the part that great but nothing
really going on there that impressed me
i thought the standout was actually
clay's bang here as the uncle i thought
he was great i wasn't familiar with him
before this but
i know he played dracula recently but
i'm excited to see what he does because
he just was the best part of this film
to me but that's the thing is like at
the end of the day you watching you're
okay you know what that was a really
good episode of game of thrones that's
what i felt like i watched and that's
disappointing because with robert eggers
you want to leave thinking about it
talking about it you know letting it
just
soak in on you i don't think that
happens here i think it's really just
this box office blockbuster now he's
doing and that is just something i'm
just a little worried about and i don't
want it to go that trajectory for him
where he starts escaping what he's you
know known for which makes him in that
different level of directors and writers
but that's something confusing me too
because it's so hard to review something
like this because for what it is it does
an excellent job like there's i don't
fault it for anything in that department
of visuals or directing but it's again
that story it's just okay i've seen all
these story beats before i've seen this
twist i've seen this message so that's
what is just so so disappointing and
that's why i confused with some critics
who will be like oh this was his
masterpiece and his best yet but it's
like so did you not value where he
really shines in his writing the last
two films he did that you're thinking
this is his masterpiece what was it
about this just because it had a bigger
budget because i had bigger action that
it's a better film that doesn't make
sense to me i think that actually takes
it down so i'm giving this one an 8.1
please don't confuse that i'm thinking i
didn't like this film i really like this
film and i think that it's something i
would definitely see again in theaters
just to have fun but it's just strange
to me robert eggers is doing a film that
i can shut my brain down on and not
really have to really think let me know
though maybe you guys had a different
reaction to it this is how i feel though
and i think it's definitely number three
out of his films i still think the witch
was the best then the lighthouse and
this was you know a full point drop in
quality which is really disappointing
but still solid and again
in those other departments that's not
writing awesome but
writing is the most important and i need
to feel something and i need to think
about something when i go to the movies
and if you're just going to make another
revenant
mixed with game of thrones and a little
bit of lion king sprinkled in you know
okay cool like i'm happy i can see you
can work well with a big budget but
i just feel like he is better than this
he's more of a higher ceiling and i hope
he doesn't start falling into things
that are gonna kind of keep him boxed in
because that's what i was worried about
when i saw what he was planning to do
next and that's exactly what ended up
happening so it's strange to me they
don't see that happening ahead of time
either so
who knows but let me know what you
thought i'd love to hear your thoughts i
read every comment and try to respond as
many as i can let me know what you
thought about all of robert eggers films
and where would you kind of rank them
i'd like to hear that as well and please
follow me at steve varley show on
twitter instagram and tick tock for more
of me and i'll see you next time